hey today we're going to talk about
hyper what's the difference between
hyperthyroidism and hypo well I'm going
to talk about hyper hypo any gland on
the body I want to give you some
principles on that hyper means too much
excess and hypo means a deficiency or
not enough of something so if we
relating it to the thyroid for example
let's just take a look at how this works
you have a gland that originates or
communicates a hormone hormones or
communications so the gland makes the
hormone it produces and receives the
hormone going back because these
hormones are on a kind of an on-off
feedback loop and so they come back in
the influence over here and they call
that negative and positive feedback so
if I were to talk to you right now and
you were to receive that message through
your ear into your brain and then give
me some acknowledgement that would be
the feedback I'm talking about so then I
would feel I would be heard and I would
need to continue talking anymore so a
good example is just with your kids if
they're listening to you and they comply
with doing the dishes
then you don't need to say anything else
right so but if that thing is ignored oh
my goodness then that gland will start
working hyper mode and start producing
more and more and more communication so
in some cases what causes a hyper is the
failing of the returned communication to
turn that thing off
because the off switch is not is broken
ok so that's one thing and so that's one
thing and then the other thing is that
the environment your glands are very
sensitive to your environment and stress
and whatever your experience in your
environment stress can definitely cause
a hyper mode especially in the adrenal
glands the stress glands on top of the
kidney if you're always stressed out
that adrenal is going to pump a lot of
adrenaline and cortisol out and you
start getting away you can't sleep and
you start breaking down you start
getting older all these wonderful things
or
right so I had this lady who had this
problem and she went in a very very long
trip overseas in a part of the country
that is on some country that's very very
laid back and showed out all of her
adrenal symptoms just cleared up like
that all of her endocrine symptoms that
she had from a hyper state just
completely went away and she started
losing weight and she was not actually
cutting calories and she was eating
worse actually eating more fat in more
calories and things and even sweets so
she comes back eats less eats better and
then falls apart again
so I know for a fact that stress can
majorly influence your glands your gland
health and they usually kind of what
they'll do they'll initially make it
hyper and then you burn out and then it
becomes a hypo so hypose can come from a
long-term burnout of pushing pushing
pushing pushing accumulating stress
getting old and then just kind of going
downhill but also your foods can
influence this as well and especially
with the gland called the pancreas when
you eat sugar that pancreas responds by
pumping out insulin to lower the sugar
in your blood so if you're doing this
too much and I love I love how people
say well I'm just eating normal amounts
of sugar wait a second what is normal
amounts of sugar the average person has
145 pounds of sugar a year like even a
cup of so a juice for example has like
what 13 teaspoons that's like way way
way way too much and that's enough to
really jack up and hyper that pancreas
to the point of creating a trauma every
time you eat something like that and
then eventually becomes a hypo and you
get diabetes type 1 where you don't
produce the insulin anymore and then
you're you're pretty much screwed
so diet can influence the gland stress
and one more thing
it's called endocrine disruptors and
those are the chemicals in the
environment that's that's the food that
chemicals in the food the hormones and
the food the and
products the genetically modified foods
the pesticides in the foods all that
greatly influences the gland because it
acts like a sturgeon that's why they
call it not just endocrine disruptors
but that region disruptors as well so an
endocrine disruptors anything that
mimics estrogen so we're going to just
shut that thing down and we're going to
create a little cyst in nodules so if
people have like nodules in their
thyroid or assist in their thyroid or a
growth or fibrocystic browser or cysts
on the ovaries what that comes from is
environmental estrogen mimickers and so
in that case they need to clean that up
clean up the diet and start consuming
foods that are anti estrogen ik like the
cruciferous vegetables and one thing
about those sista as a remedy sea kelp
is a really good thing for nodules
especially of the breast and ovaries the
ovary and breast respond very very good
to seek help fYI that's like seaweed so
those are the three things that highly
influence whether someone's hyper or
hypo hyper is more of an endocrine
disruptor situation unless it's the
pancreas and then it's sugar well unless
it's the adrenal and then it's stress
but the point is that any one of these
can either make you hyper or hypo and
you just have to do this one last
technique to figure it out ask yourself
when did you start noticing signs of
hyper or hypo and then what occurred
just before that and you're going to
find you're going to get a clue as a
diet change a stress change or an
exposure to some endocrine disrupter
hope that help I'll see you next video